the Joe Rogan experience yeah like
people in the Amazon or something like
that they're they're probably the only
ones that have a chance yep
what's the matter Jim you see this going
around the story about this new company
that can upload your brain but it kills
you what yeah a startup is pitching a
mind uploading service that is 100%
fatal I think they're taking like people
that are already terminal patients and
whatnot that's their first sort of and
then upload their mind yeah I don't know
I didn't they're gonna give you some
[ __ ] scrambled version of what its
gonna be all swastika like like we found
grandpa's brain and we're gonna upload
it now and you'll be able to look into
his thoughts oh it's all dicks grandpa's
all Dickson and Nazi memorabilia
preserve your brain and uploaded company
its chemical solution can keep a body
intact for hundreds of years maybe
thousands as a statue of frozen glass
what the idea is that some day in the
future scientists will scan your bricked
brain and turn it into a computer
simulation so they don't even know how
to do it yet this is [ __ ] that way
someone like a lot like you though not
exactly you will smell the flowers again
in a data server somewhere Wyatt
okay the story's a grisly twist though
for neck Holmes procedure to work it's
essential that the brain be fresh the
company says its plan is to connect
people with terminal illnesses to a
heart-lung machine in order to pump its
mix of scientific and bombing chemicals
into the big car Lloyd arteries in their
necks well they're still alive
though under general anesthesia thank
god you put them under before you kill
them because we want them to experience
any pain for they going to the great
frozen glass statue beyond there's a
waiting list of course it's a waiting
list a bunch of [ __ ] idiots Jesus
Christ people are stupid there's a you
know hundreds of thousands of people
signed up to die on Mars do you know
that to have the opportunity to be one
of the first people to die on Mars
hundreds of thousand
people signed up yeah you don't want to
be the first to be locked in a spaceship
for six months with a bunch of other
people so [ __ ] stupid they're willing
to die on Mars yeah then you get there
they're just talking about social
justice the entire way all the way talk
about veganism and social justice and
you know Elon Musk on first Mars
explorers good chance you'll die Oh a
chance how about 100 percent you're
gonna die with you stay here stay here
get good chance you'll die you're dying
everyone's dying you're gonna die that's
the fucked-up thing we just don't want
everybody to die all at once we're cool
with small groups people that are brown
that die in caves on the other part of
the world if we could be convinced
they're primitive they hold these
ridiculous beliefs and we don't even
know them right so we're just gonna kill
them with robots
yeah it's somebody out there who cares
it's not us yeah I think just the rate
of change is happening so fast there's
gonna be a lot of dumb [ __ ] like this it
happens along the way Gorge like the
bell-bottoms of Technology it's like
what is that what the [ __ ] were they
thinking it's just gonna keep keep
happening like that
[Applause]